the current firearms and guns are 21.
and then just escalated us from there
sequarius McGrath was a major Liverpool
gangster he once roamed these streets
where guns are used to enforce drug
Empires I was mentioning no share cause
I was mixing in those situations so I'm
a bit of a hypocrite to stand here now
and say you know their absolutes come
which they are but I was one I was once
that same scumbag and you put guns on
the streets by your own admission I
think in massive volumes
when Olivia was shot the community was
in Conflict outrage balanced against
loyalty and fear of being called a grass
probably people are going to be
reluctance and I think depend on who
commits the mayor if they're established
gang members then people are going to be
more reluctance police struggled to get
the evidence they needed for Olivia's
murder
everyone says there's a cold no glasses
no no this no doubt if it benefits can
most they will the world grass each
other up it's what benefits them they're
not just going to do for charity but for
the members of the public who witness a
big crime how difficult is it for them
do you think to give information it's
going to be overwhelm it's going to be
scary and they're not really going to
want to get involved well when it's a
child I think there will be goes out to
win them but they will worry weren't
they about their own safety afterwards
if people find out but that's that's for
the police to go no worry but that's
with the police to to reassure them that
they're gonna protect them and ensure
their safety
police heard from one key witness early
on but got no direct evidence no one who
could identify the gunman no forensics
no weapon a reward of fifty thousand
pounds wasn't doing the trick
it was boosted with another hundred
thousand from a mystery donor the
charity topped it up to a record 200 000
pounds
when I heard there was a reluctance for
people to come forward and testify
that's what really got my back up I
thought well I'm gonna do something
about this it was an amount that would
make people sit up and take notice the
bottom line is that this was horrific
the murder of a young girl it doesn't
come much worse than that sixteen years
ago a young boy Rhys Jones was shot dead
only a few miles from here I reported on
it sicarius was in prison but we both
heard the loud calls for change
they always say that whenever there's a
young person stabbed or shots
um desire enough is enough and they're
going to take a standby communities
never do it's just all words a couple of
days or a couple weeks later they just
go back to doing what he was doing and
forget about it it's only the families
that are left suffering last August
Olivia's death was one of three gun
murders in a week
there have been two more in the city
since
Martin brunt Sky News in Liverpool